in dieser sonderfolge des bücher
podcasts ist antje rávic strubel mit
ihrem roman blaue frau am buchmesse
stand der faz zu gast es moderiert
andrea diener
hallo willkommen
schön dass sie da sind hab ich auch mal
ja maske absetzen endlich und schön dass
sie da sind antje rávic strubel
sie haben den buchpreis gewonnen mit
ihrem buch die blaue frau da stets
erschienen bei s.fischer
erstmal herzlichen glückwunsch dazu
vielen dank schön dass wir sie am stand
besuchen hallo dürfen hallo
so
als ich das buch angefangen habe zu
lesen habe ich mich ich hatte ein
bisschen probleme rein zu kommen man
tastet sich sehr langsam in dieses buch
rein in diese welt rein und auch sehr
langsam an diese protagonistin heran und
irgendwann wurde mir klar dass das
ästhetisches mittel ist weil auch diese
protagonistin sich sehr langsam an ihre
welt hinein tastet und ihre umgebung und
sich selbst erst mal wahrnehmen muss was
ist das für eine figur der wir da
begegnen na ja sie haben es gerade schon
gesagt also sie kommen so langsam da
rein wie sie tatsächlich via diener die
hauptfigur
auch da rein kommt nämlich in diese
etwas ungewohnte oder sehr ungewohnte
umgebung sie ist ja da mehr oder weniger
gestrandet in diesem plattenbau und
setzt sich eigentlich ihre äußere welt
zusammen die ihre innenwelt im grunde
ersetzen muss weil sie an ihre innenwelt
moment nicht so richtig ran kommt
und ja so beginnt das buch und diese
diese figur ist eine die aus einem aus
einem zweiten buch stammt eigentlich
damals war sie zwölf jetzt ist sie 20
ich bin ein bisschen älter geworden
inzwischen als sie also mehr jahre für
mich als für diener vergangen die
erzählte wirklichkeit und die
tatsächlich wirklichkeit sind ja nicht
immer so ganz eins zu eins
und damals als sie zwölf ist sie so ein
verlorener teenager in diesem sport da
gibt es eigentlich nur touristen und
ältere leute die diesen sport am laufen
halten in kirchen
darauf genau ja oder roman unter schnee
war daraus und gar nicht nach 20 jahren
genau stimmt genau
und ich dachte immer was ist aus dir
geworden also die hat mich irgendwie
interessiert weil die hatte so eine
widerständigkeit die hat die hat so ihr
eigenes ding gemacht irgendwie sie hat
ihre freunde aus dem internet dies war
bei mal so in chatrooms unterwegs und
naja und dann habe ich versucht mich auf
sie zu zuschreiben oder sie wieder näher
zu holen und hat sie eigentlich in die
gleiche wohnung hinein geschrieben in
der ich damals als ich anfing den roman
zu schreiben
in der ich damals gewohnt habe und zwar
in helsinki in einem plattenbau und
diese adina hat sie nie so richtig
losgelassen überall die zeiten hinweg
und janni kann man auch nicht sagen also
eigentlich ist sie später wieder
aufgetaucht ich glaube es ging um eine
übersetzung von unter schnee und dann
habe ich mir das buch wieder vorgenommen
und war ganz überrascht dass die episode
in der adina vorkommt relativ kurz ist
weil die figur mehr irgendwie doch
intensiver im gedächtnis war
und da fing ich dann an wieder mehr über
sie nachzudenken
ich habe ja schon erwähnt dass sie sich
so die welt hinein taste dass man sich
als leser so in die welt des buches
hinein tastet wie war das denn beim
schreiben war das auch so einen etwas
tasten der vorgang oder hatten sie von
anfang an einen plan was mit dieser
adina apa sie hat mir im gegenteil aber
ich hatte natürlich eine gute erzählt
situation also man sich überlegt die
kommt aus tschechien dann ist er in
helsinki wie kommt die dahin was macht
sie da so wie geht's dir was mit ihr los
so fing ich irgendwie an zu schreiben
und da ich wollte so vieles so viele
sachen herausfinden war neugierig und
schrieb dann los
das ja ist aber unterschiedlich also
manchmal geht es schneller manchmal
dauert dann bleibt man hängen und denkt
man hat irgendwie so ein abgrund vor
sich wie kommt man jetzt über diesen
abgrund darüber also ganz
unterschiedlich aber tastend das ist ein
diener das bin ich die dann tastet
sie haben sehr lange an diesem roman
geschrieben
was war denn der widerstand war dass der
stoff war das waren das äußere umstände
was war das ja ganz hundertprozentig
erklären kann ich das glaube ich nicht
also ich hatte das gefühl dieses buch
muss mit mir wachsen oder ich muss mit
dem buch wachsen oder mit diesem
material wachsen
im laufe des schreibens stellte sich
heraus dass es doch ein sehr komplexes
buch wird ich musste viel ich habe
angefangen viel zu recherchieren
verschiedene dinge irgendwie haben mich
interessiert habe mich mit bestimmten
fragen beschäftigt das hat das etwas
verlangsamt
adina war auch so schwierig also die
wollte nicht aus dieser plattenbau
wohnung raus das hat mir echt probleme
bereitet ich kann mich erinnern ich habe
einen unterstelle auch zu meinem verlag
gesagt na ja ich schreibe gerade dieses
buch über diese frauen dieser
plattenbauwohnung die will da nicht raus
also die begeisterung mal ein bisschen
verhalten
so also ist war es war so ein
widerständige also auch so eine
widerständige figur aber auch toll ich
habe auch 60 seiten über sie geschrieben
wo ich sie auf eine demo geschickt habe
die wollte da nicht hin das hat alles
nicht funktioniert musste ich alles
wieder löschen also so das war das eine
und das andere war und danach fragen sie
wahrscheinlich weil ich das schon öfter
jetzt gesagt habe
ich wurde an einer bestimmten stelle
sehr zornig und mit zorn lässt sich
schlecht schreiben zumindest keinen
literarischen text und deswegen musste
ich
das manuskript beiseite legen und den
zorn ein bisschen verrauchen lassen
ging es da um also wir müssen vielleicht
ein bisschen auf die geschichte von
adina doch noch mal kommen adina
zwischen helsinki und diesen
tschechischen ort wo sie her stammt
macht strandet sie so ein bisschen
zwischendrin erstmal in berlin lernt
dort eine fotografin kennen ricky über
die wir vielleicht auch noch mal kurz zu
sprechen müssen und ricky vermittelt ihr
ein praktikum in einem kulturort der im
entstehen begriffen ist in einem alten
gutshaus in der uckermark und
und wir sind ja auch 2006 oder 2007 in
der uckermark also heute zieht alle welt
in die uckermark damals war das noch
nicht so der fall es war eng sollte mir
eine wirklich gottverlassene gegend die
sie auch nie so richtig betreten und
erkunden kann weil immer nachts die
wilden hunde darum laufen und sie sitzt
in diesem gutshaus pauw und er lebt
schrecklein schreckliche
missbrauchsgeschichte mit einem
deutschen kulturfunktionär also das ist
ja so ein bisschen die die kern
geschichte dieser adina
wann im laufe des schreibens kamen sie
denn darauf
ja das kristallisierte sich irgendwie
heraus dadurch dass ich irgendwann
feststellte so in meinem bekanntenkreis
immer häufiger erfuhr ich dass die oder
jene in ihrer biografie sexuellen
missbrauch erlebt hatte gleichzeitig
habe ich virginia woolf übersetzt ich
habe lust hier berlin übersetzt beides
autorin die in kindheit
sexuellen missbrauch erlebt haben und
irgendwann dachte ich dann das scheint
so normal zu sein also bin ich die
ausnahme bei mir ist das
glücklicherweise nicht passiert ich habe
mich eigentlich immer für die normalität
das ist aber oder für das was normal ist
aber ob man nicht so naja und dann
begann ich mich irgendwie mehr damit zu
beschäftigen und bei mir funktioniert
ist glaube ich immer so beim schreiben
dass wenn mich fragen umtreiben die
haben dann unter umständen eine wirkung
auf das woran ich gerade arbeite und
deswegen war dann irgendwann auch klar
warum er diener sich diese welt so
zusammensetzung was da eigentlich
passiert ist
ja also das wird beeinflusste dann die
arbeit an diesem text
es geht dann auch sehr lange um darum
also wie adina damit umgeht also die tat
selber ist gar nicht plakativ
beschrieben das ist eigentlich eher ein
bisschen eine lehrstelle im roman aber
wie sie damit umgeht und wie gerichte
damit umgehen und was sie jetzt für
möglichkeiten überhaupt hat gegen diesen
menschen vorzugehen
ich kann mir vorstellen das war auch
noch mal eine tiefere tiefere recherche
in sachen gericht gesetzgebung gerichte
welche chancen hat man wenn da überhaupt
ja das war das eben was den zorn
ausgelöst hat also während der
recherchen also oder fange ich mal
anders an also ich habe mich bei dem
buch
gefragt wie wir eigentlich mit sexueller
gewalt umgehen also wie wir persönlich
darauf reagieren also was passiert
beispielsweise wenn ich erfahre dass ein
guter freund von mir eine frau
missbraucht hat wie reagiert da was
mache ich damit
wie wir als gesellschaft damit umgehen
um und aber auch wie unsere gerichte
damit umgehen und im laufe dieser
recherchen merkte ich dass der umgang
irgendwie doch sehr miserabel ist also
das kaum fälle angezeigt werden was
daran liegt dass kaum fälle verurteilt
werden in deutschland dass die frauen
mit ihr mit mit dem täter im selben
gerichtssaal sitzen müssen eine anwältin
erzählte mir sie wird ausgelacht wenn
sie nur einen räumlichen abstand
zwischen zwischen beiden einfordert was
in skandinavien ganz anders ist da ist
ganz klar dass das über wie also durch
video übertragung funktioniert also
diese dinge haben mich schon ein
bisschen
aufgebracht und was haben sie jetzt
gefragt
eigentlich nach der recherche aber das
habe ich dann auch wirklich
gerichtsakten und studiert und ja ich
habe einige gerichtsprotokolle gelesen
ich habe mit richter innen und
anwältinnen und auch einem
strafverteidiger gesprochen der unter
anderem gesagt dass er seine
verteidigung oft darauf aufbaut dass man
sich sowieso nur sieben sekunden lang
fehlerfrei erinnern kann danach ist
erinnerung immer verfälscht es gibt
irgendwie wissenschaftliche studien
findet er als strafverteidiger ganz toll
weil er da irgendwie seine verteidigung
darauf aufbaut und dann im gegenzug muss
man sich überlegen dass eine frau die
der die dieses schreckliche zugestoßen
ist die muster irgendwie minutiös sich
daran erinnern können und sobald sie
einen fehler macht ist nicht mehr
glaubwürdig wenn man genau und dieses
ganze problem der glaubwürdigkeit ist
fand ich es doch eines war es nicht
wirklich gut
verhandelt weil gut betrachtet wird oder
darüber müsste man noch mal neu
nachdenken weil wenn das tatsächlich so
ist mit den sieben sekunden dann kann
man das eigentlich gar nicht so
begründen
adina hat ja mehrere fluchtpunkte in die
sie sich zurückzieht das ist in ihrer
jugend dieser virtuelle raum eines
internetforums und das ist dann später
dieser etwas sehr trostlose
plattenbausiedlung in helsinki
man darf sich jetzt auch keine nicht so
eine aus deutsche plattenbausiedlung so
nachwende vorstellen die sind schon ein
bisschen besser in finnland aber
ich wollte fragen also dieses helsinki
erscheint ja doch immer so ein bisschen
kühl und sehr kalt und
das ausgerechnet dieser sehr sehr kalte
ort zu einem fluchtpunkt wird wo sie
sich dann langsam wieder zu sich kommen
kann
das ist schon bemerkenswert weil das
jetzt beides nicht die wir also etwas
unwirtliche orte sind nun würde man
meinen so einem internetforum so
menschen sind die sich noch nie gesehen
haben und eben da dieses kalt der elsing
kino leute nicht unbedingt auf der
straße sind und den ganzen tag ein
cappuccino trinken also sind was was
macht diese unwirtliche orte
ausgerechnet zu geeigneten flucht
punkten
naja dieses elsing also mit unwirklich
kann ich jetzt mit helsinki nicht so
viel anfangen also ich hab selber in
helsinki daneben ein halbes jahr
verbracht und ich finde diese stadt sehr
offen und sehr zugänglich und auch sehr
sozial also meine da sind die
bushaltestellen in der entfernung von
200 oder 100 200 metern damit man bei
schlechten wetter nicht so weit laufen
muss also toll eigentlich deswegen also
helsinki ist sie ja nur so ein zufall
sword sie ist eigentlich immer nur nach
norden gegangen weil sie dachte da ist
es dunkel man sieht man sie nicht also
das der einzige grund warum sie von
diesem kulturzentrum immer nach norden
geben und landet sie halt in helsinki
und dieser ort ist für sie vielleicht
eher deshalb wichtig weil er weil sie
nicht erkannt wird weil sie irgendwo ist
was wo sie sich sicher fühlen kann und
eben auch nicht sich verfolgt fühlen
muss und was ja dann auch am ende nicht
wirklich der fall ist aber es ist erst
mal so eine ja es ist ein fluchtpunkt wo
sie schön weit weg ist von dem was ihr
zugestoßen ist
wir müssen glaube ich noch mal auf
berlin zurückkommen und auf ricky und
auf die zeit die sie dort verlebt das
war ja noch so ein etwas unschuldige
zeit da ist sie ja noch dass das junge
tschechische mädchen das aufgebrochen
ist und die stadt und die welt zu
erobern und sie will geografie studieren
geografie geologie wissenschaftler
wissenschaften
und ricky die fotografen findet sie
macht aufnahmen von ihr
man könnte sagen es ist so ein bisschen
ein ausnutzen das verhältnis was sie zu
dieser adina hat
möchte sie für ihre kunst nutzen
und es kommen immer wieder auf die
schulter
die sprache auf diese ost und west
geschichten also berlin mit ostberlin
westberlin geteilte stadt das ist was
neues für adina und auch dass die rigi
und ihre freundinnen sich immer wieder
bei ostdeutschland westdeutschland
unterhalten und eigentlich mit adidas
tschechischer herkunft gar nicht so
richtig was anfangen können
ja ja es ist eine interessante gruppe in
die erdinger der gerät in berlin so ein
bisschen alternativ so halb künstlerisch
kurier also regiert so eine coole die
irgendwie dann diener fotografiert und
naja das ist sonne ist eine interessante
figur war zum einen bringt sie etwas in
der diener zum vorschein was sie selber
vielleicht noch gar nicht so richtig
wahrgenommen hat also in den chatrooms
nennt sie sich immer der letzte
mohikaner weil sie ja der letzte
teenager ist da gibt es diese parallele
und rigi sie träge bringt in einem foto
diesen letzten mohikaner plötzlich zum
vorschein also diener meint diesen
ricaner zu sehen in sich also der gewinn
plötzlich so eine so eine andere
wirklichkeit also das bedeutet natürlich
auch auf seine fluide geschlechter
identität hin das war irgendwie eine
figur der stärke ist für anja genau der
wird am ende wird es ein richtiges
kraftfeld der eigentlich hilft ihr diese
dieser dieser letzte amerikaner die
ganze sache irgendwie durchzustehen
ja und gleichzeitig ist ricky aber eben
auch die die sie so ein bisschen ja wie
sie schon sagten ausnutzt und dann
fatalerweise dieses praktikum vermittelt
wobei das kann sie natürlich nicht
wissen also aber letztendlich geht es
auch da also es geht mit dem ganzen buch
immer auch um die frage wie nehmen wir
einander war also wie nehmen wir auch
einander war in bestimmten unter
bestimmten machtverhältnissen also
dieses ost west verhältnis was ja auch
zwischen ricky und diesen freundinnen
die eines aus dem osten regis aus dem
besten eine rolle spielt dann auch
zwischen ost und westeuropa interessant
ja auch das adina die nach also aus
tschechien dann nach deutschland kommt
dann wird sie natürlich sofort als aus
mitteleuropäischen wahrgenommen die dann
wiederum leonidas aus island kennen
lernt mit ihm ein jahr zusammen ist und
auch das ist ein interessantes
verhältnis weil leoni das ist eigentlich
wird im westen im grunde auch als er aus
dem osten wahrgenommen für diener könnte
er aber weil er so ein erfolgreicher
politiker ist und irgendwie sehr
eloquent ohne ende redet er mit einem
westler assoziiert werden also auch da
gibt es unterschiedliche
machtverhältnisse und wie wir uns dann
jeweils in diesen verhältnissen
wahrnehmen das ist eine frage die ich
mir in diesem buch gestellt habe und sie
ist angenehm wenig schwarz weiß sondern
er wirklich so eine ganze zersplitterte
und sehr komplexe angelegenheit also
nicht nur ost und west sondern
kommt halt wirklich auf den standpunkt
an das wird diese linien verschieben
sich ja auch ständig je nachdem wo man
selber steht und von wo aus man guckt
nimmt man natürlich anders war und wird
man auch anders wahrgenommen also es ist
so wie was verstehen wir als zentrum und
was die peripherie europas kommt auch
immer darauf an von wo man guckt wo man
sich gerade aufhält wir müssen unbedingt
noch auf die blaue frau zu sprechen
kommen die blaue frau die den titel
dieses buches
stellt kommt auch als figur in diesem
buch vor und es heißt wenn sie auftaucht
muss die erzählung innehalten was hat es
mit dieser geheimnisvollen figur auf
sich
ja ohne die blaue frau hätte ich dieses
buch nicht schreiben können
wobei mir am anfang gar nicht klar war
dass die blaue frau was mit diesem buch
zu tun hat also ich dachte ursprünglich
ich schreibe zwei verschiedene texte und
der eine bestand darin dass diese blaue
frau auftauchte in einem hafen von
helsinki was auch in diesem buch so
beschrieben wird sich mir zuwendete und
anfangen anfing mit mir zu sprechen also
im kopf aber sie war sehr lebendig und
ich dann immer diese gespräche quasi mit
schrieb also ich dachte das wird so ein
fragmentarisch lyrische texte also wir
unterhalten uns wir reden über das
schreiben wir reden über das über das
sprechen auch darüber wer wessen
geschichte erzählen darf wie erzählen
überhaupt funktioniert
und dann war es war mir irgendwie
vielleicht einfach nur aus einer
rhythmischen entscheidung heraus klar
dass die blaue frau da sie sowieso im
moment einen so blitzartigen momenten in
diese in diese andere geschichte hinein
greifen muss sie sind auch so momente
von schönheit von luft holen
ja also für mich war vielleicht unter
einem nachhinein wurde mir klar das ist
auch eine möglichkeit eigentlich meine
eigene position zu der geschichte die
ich erzähle zu klären oder zumindest zu
hinterfragen und das mache ich aber im
schreiben sehr häufig dass ich mich
frage wer erzählt eigentlich wer bin ich
da eigentlich die das erzählen warum
erzähle ich überhaupt diese geschichte
und warum erzählen sie diese geschichte
tja also mal abgesehen von adina die
mich irgendwie interessiert hat
[Musik]
habe ich als ich selber in finnland war
ist mir glaube ich noch mal so eine eine
andere sicht auf dieses europa
aufgegangen und das hat was also in
finnland ist ja so eine so eine
schnittstelle zwischen ost und west und
da ist er geht der blick viel schneller
mal ins baltikum also tallinn ist von
helsinki 80 kilometer luftlinie entfernt
man guckt viel schneller mal nach
osteuropa und in unterhaltung mit
wissenschaftler ihn wurde mir klar dass
die art wie sich in
in den baltischen staaten an die
verbrechen des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
erinnert wird doch sehr anders ist als
wie man sich in westeuropa daran
erinnert was einfach daran liegt dass
man es erst seit 91 überhaupt tun kann
vorher waren die erinnerung eingefroren
es war nicht erlaubt da ist es gibt also
eine ganzen ganz anderen zugriff auf
diese zeit darüber wird viel zu wenig
eigentlich gesprochen darüber denkt man
eigentlich auch nicht nach habe ich auch
nicht vorher und das hat was mit mir zu
tun da ich in der ddr aufgewachsen bin
auch wenn die innerdeutschen
verhältnisse natürlich noch mal anders
sind aber da gab es zumindest sonne also
gab's ein interesse was auch auf meine
biographie zurück geht und das spiegelt
sich ja dann auch in dem text über
diesen leonidas figur wieder und eben
auch verschiedene arten von ausnutzen
und
sich überlegen fühlen oder sich
unterlegen fühlen
vielen vielen dank an trilantic strubel
mit der blauen frau und mit dem
buchpreis für freis danke ihnen dass sie
da waren wir vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]